la cérémonie des césar avec un triomphe
pour les invasions barbares québécois
denys arcand de récompense pour julie
depardieu et a parfois une déception
pour les grands favoris les temps forts
de la soirée avec pascal décent et carl
tricot
jamais les prix et il a été servi hier
soir denys arcand
ces invasions barbares coproduite par la
france remporte les trois césars les
plus prestigieux meilleur réalisateur
meilleur film et scénario devant les
favoris bon voyage de jean paul
rappeneau ou pas sur la bouche d'alain
resnais
comme l'a dit quelqu'un de cela on avait
déjà céline dion autre jolie surprise le
doublé de julie depardieu à la fois
meilleur espoir et meilleur second rôle
pour la petite lili de claude miller
le papa n'a pas résisté à la tentation
de monter sur scène
je ne m'y attendais pas mais il est là
il est partout vous savez c'est mon
fardeau comme on dit il est partout il
me précède tout le temps quelque part
mais bon je me suis fais moi ça va pour
les meilleurs acteurs les césar ont
récompensé à la fois le comédien mitico
s'enrôlent omar sharif pour monsieur
ibrahim et les fleurs du coran
y a pas de cas désespérés et la
génération qui monte
sylvie testud pour stupeur et
tremblements d'alain corneau môle 1 mais
ça valait le prix moment j'avais pas les
lézards ça valait le coup pour la
rencontre avec alain jund
pour le film je me suis peu amusé parce
que vous mais l'heure n'était pas qu à
l'amusement 7 agnès jaoui qui a été la
plus longuement applaudie lorsqu'elle a
condamné la réforme du statut des
intermittents et annoncé qu'un contre
protocole serait déposée mercredi
prochain à l'assemblée nationale